[Music]  again my old and TARDIS friend  wish me good night anticipate fright you  watch over me and a quiver silently and  though I have grown I'm still scared  does that make me we are maybe undersea  [Music]  they told me you'd fade abandoned me  with a but I into attached to the  terrors earth you cast you watch over me  as I wake you up from my squeeze the  madness death quo and I'm still too  scared to sleep  [Music]  and I fear we are maybe I'm just  [Music]  you  then you come stay to come what's in my  mind as I transferred into a world that  isn't quite so kind of my bed and I they  sacrifice help me my strength in my  chair so I so I won't be weak and I'll  be this to see  [Music]  [Music]  I'm still too scared to sleep  [Music]